hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
I've been playing Friday the 13th this
week and although it has quite a few
glitches it's one of the most fun games
I played this year and by fun I mean
terrifying and stressful of course but
it's all worthwhile when you hear a 40
year old man screaming like a
five-year-old girl rock egg playing as
Jason may be the highlight of this game
but you'll spend most of your time
playing as a counselor about 99% of your
time in fact so let's go through 7 tips
and tricks to survive your nightmare as
a counselor I won't be telling you to
close doors and scavenge because you
already know that but one of the basics
that deserve going over again is
communication if you're in a Friday the
13th Lobby and you can't hear another
person speaking then be prepared for a
bad time talking is the most important
thing you can do here talk to the other
counselors whenever they are close
enough to hear you you may be searching
for a set of car keys which another
person may already have also let people
know what you are found and use the map
when you find one of course to give
directions to items you have seen on
your travels pick up a radio and talk to
people further away too and if you're
going to die let people know where you
are and what you have on your carcass
before you pop your clogs even though I
said communication is key it has a few
drawbacks - and Jason can hear
everything you say if he's close enough
in proximity that is my tip is to turn
off your microphone when Jason is near
if he can't find you by sight then he'll
track you down by listening to your
whimpers don't be afraid to turn off
your mic while you're hiding but make
sure it goes back on the second he
leaves and you see another counselor if
you're feeling super cocky and want to
talk to Jason why not try to give him
some misinformation - in one of our
matches we told Jason we were fixing a
car in a certain location but actually
escapes in a different vehicle
completely Drummond avoiding from all my
problem
the adjacent we'll come back to visit
soon I'm sure you already know this one
but just in case keep one ear on the
soundtrack and music the music in
particular is your key ability to know
where Jason is always listen up for the
music to change and plan accordingly you
knew that already though so let's move
on managing and controlling your fear is
another pivotal aspect of this game as
your character becomes more afraid
you'll lose visibility and it becomes
easy as a Jason to rip you to shreds so
here's what you do
picking a character that composes always
one option but keep with another person
I don't mean run as a group of eight
just two people is perfect this will
drastically stop your character from
becoming scarce and gurning like a
buffoon that's how you can tell how
fearful you are by the way those ugly
mugs only a mother could love the wider
the eyes the mosque edge listen you are
there are many things you can do to calm
down and other things which will send
you over the edge if you are alone in
the dark off the trail if you see Jason
or one of the dead bodies left behind or
of course if he's pursuing you all of
these effects your character so use your
torch in the dark but keep in mind it's
easier for him to see you when you do
that when you're locking those dogs that
also reduces your CSU but please please
don't go around running jog or walk
everywhere stamina management is so
important and running around like a
headless chicken will not help in the
slightest Jason can sense you running
far more than he can with your jogging
or just walking around so leave it for
when he's chasing you your stamina is
the redline underneath the compass in
the bottom corner jogging will drain it
but walking and stopping will refill the
meter
don't waste it because you will need it
when Jason starts jumping around the map
and stalking you don't run when you're
around people either you may not be
there in five minutes but that person
could be and you're leading Jason right
to them
check the objective screen often
surviving 20 minutes can be extremely
tricky so a knowledge of how to escape
is imperative at any point you can
simply press the touchpad on ps4 and it
will bring up the map if you found one
and it will also let you know how far
through all the objectives you are for
example if one of your fellow
councillors has completed an action such
as adding fuel to a car it will pop up
immediately so check this screen often
as you can see in this one the four-door
car has already been and gone all the
parts have been done and we've also
called for help
let's quickly just go over the option
calling for help will allow one unlucky
victim or escapee to respawn as tommy
simply find the radio cabin to sort this
and send out a quick message we need
your help
Jason is killing us we need your help
it's also possible to form the police to
drastically cut down the duration of the
game for this one you'll need a fuse to
repair the connection and then jump
inside the house and call the cops is
this a police help
Jason's here Jason's here killing us
killing everyone they will show up at
one of the exit points in five minutes
but you won't know which one until those
five minutes have elapsed to escape in a
car you need fuel a battery and car keys
but use your vehicle wisely as there is
a four-seater under 2 theta you want to
get up a load of Georgia bring friends
I'm really sorry Raquel finally you can
get away in a boat and it only requires
fuel and the propeller not enough horror
games have speedboats in them
bring breath and just to go over it one
more time check the map screen often to
see what has been completed and what
needs to be done one last nugget of
information when leaving a house check
to see if there is a really owner by
turn on the radio to trick Jason into
checking that cabin but only do this if
you have no plans on returning to this
area this should buy you and your fellow
counselors a little bit more time away
from that big bastard
so remember to team up with another
player communicate with a mic but turley
top one Jason is hunting you don't
sprint unless you have to check the
opportunity screen often be sure to
listen to the music to check for Jason's
whereabouts and try to distract Jason to
help your buddy
seven ways to stay alive in Friday the
13th I'm Adam from Playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure I'll see you next
time